it's as if it was in her blood belly
dancing is my life
when I'm dancing I'm happy I'm elated
when I'm not on the stage I'm without a
soul but she wasn't born with this
traditional Egyptian dance
suryya Carvalho is six thousand miles
away from her native Brazil a
professional belly dancer working in
Cairo the entertainment capital of the
Arab world I came here for the art I
worked in Brazil for ten years but I
came here because the art is very
special I feel a big responsibility to
get the dancers right because there are
no Egyptians that I'm a foreigner
carrying on this tradition some people
believe belly dancing dates back to the
time of the Pharaohs others say had
developed as a pelvic exercise a way to
help women in childbirth feel less pain
this is the oldest loot store in Cairo
for almost a hundred years it's been
crafting the instrument of the dance Eid
Muhammad Ali has witnessed the rise and
fall of the art from right here in his
neighborhood years ago you would find
belly dancers and musicians standing
outside ready to go to weddings or
parties but now it's different in the
last 20 years as Islamic conservatives
have preached a more puritanical
morality some people have come to
believe that belly dancing is Haram or
taboo that attitude upsets foois woozy
she's one of the few Egyptians taking it
up professionally
by the government it's legal and we have
licenses it's not something embarrassing
I'm not embarrassed I don't listen to
them I believe in what I'm doing to me
what I'm doing is right and I'm not
going to pay attention it would others
say some Egyptians who remember that
special magic feel that for all their
skills up incoming dancers like seraya
still lack something essential the
foreigners they learn faster than
Egyptians but they have the fitness for
it but on the other hand they don't have
a feeling for the music where the dance
itself it's not like you can teach
someone and should just go out and do it
no you have to reveal it and they'll act
the Egyptians sense of it but after
years of study it's second nature for
Sariah her dedication is putting her in
the spotlight Kairos Sheraton hotel is
one of the best places in the city to
perform a stage many dancers dream of
tonight she gets to live that dream